à presque 150 ans le château de la
couldre pourrait bien s'offrir une
seconde vie après avoir accueilli la
communauté d'agglomération de saint
quentin la commune de montigny le
bretonneux s'est portée candidate pour
transformer cette demeure en ehpad cette
candidature trouve sa cause dans
l'émigration désigné mon teint
aujourd'hui une partie des personnes
retraitées des ménages intra muros
passons d'un pavillon un appartement de
là est née l'idée d'une résidence
services accompagnant un ehpad cette
installation sera divisé en deux parties
les services administratifs et sociaux
seront installés dans le château l'autre
partie la résidence services dédiés aux
personnes plus autonomes sera construite
à l'entrée du site la capacité d'accueil
donc de la résidence service et environ
une soixantaine de logements et les
pâtes donc sera de 84 lits 80 en
hébergement complet et 4 l'y attend à un
hébergement partiel c'est-à-dire des
hébergements temporaires soit pour
permettre durée pays soit un retour
d'hôpital pour accompagner les personnes
une convention devrait être signée avec
l'hôpital de plaisir pour prendre en
charge des personnes âgées devant être
hospitalisé le seul point
d'interrogation réside dans la présence
ou non d'autres projets pour le site du
château de la couldre dont le parc sera
toujours ouvert au public si montigny
remporte l'appel d'offres du conseil
général l'ehpad pourrait ouvrir ses
portes fin 2014